[موسيقى]
اهلا وسهلا بكم في حلقه جديده من برنامجكم
الندوى الصالون اليوم عن التاريخ السعودي
وما ادراك ما التاريخ السعودي وان شئت
فقلت تاريخ الجزيره العربيه الذي كان وما
يزال وسيظل
منهلا للدارسين والباحثين ومصدرا للافكار
الجديده والتصورات الجديده ولكن هذه المره
من خلال استعراض او الاتكاء على عكازين
عكاز علم الاجتماع علم اجتماع البداوه
تحديدا وهذا الاسم لفت انتباهي بالمناسبه
ومن خلال استعراض الارشيف وخاصه الارشيف
العثماني فسنمشي على هذين العكازين او
هذين الساقين لنلجا الى
بهو التاريخ السعودي والجزيره العربيه
ولمساعدتنا على هذا المضي وهذا المشي في
هذا البهو الكبير يسرنا ان يكون شريكنا في
الندوه اليوم الدكتور اسماعيل السلامات
الباحث في علم الاجتماع وتحديدا
اجتماع البداوه حياك الله دكتور ما هو على
المصنع علم الاجتماع البدوي هو احد ميادين
علم الاجتماع العام ويهتم بدراسه
المجتمعات البدويه في مراحل تطورها من
مرحله الرعي والتنقل الى مرحله الاستقرار
ومن ثم الى مرحله التحضر
والحقيقه انا اجريت دراسه اكاديميه في
جامعه دمشق تناولت فيها قبيله عنزه
الوائليه فدرست هذه درست هذه القبيله في
مراحل تطورها التاريخي والاجتماعي
والسياسي ما بين الجزيره العربيه وبلاد
الشام واخدتها كنموذج تطبيقي للعمل اذا
اعتقد حتى الماجستير والدكتوراه في
الماجستير في قبيله عنزي في القيم
المجتمعيه الحقيقه العنوان مثير وتعتقد
اظن دكتور كمان الباحثين الاجانب غير
العرب
اوروبيين وغير الاوروبيين بس بشكل خاص
اوروبيين ايضا وفدوا الى المنطقه وكتبوا
عنها الكثير سواء على شكل رحلات رحله
بلغريف ورحله داوتي وغيرهم او على شكل
دراسات احيانا او مزج بين الامرين يعني
معايشه ودراسات يعني على ذكر عنزه تذكر
دراسه التشيكي
اخلاق روى الله وعاداتهم مسمى نفسه موسى
الرويلي
دراسه وغيرهم لكن هل تعتقد ان الباحث
العربي ابن البيئه لديهم ميزه مثلا اذا
درس هذه الاشياء يعني تميزه عن الباحث
الاجنبي الفرق ما بين دراسه الباحث العربي
او دراسه المستشرق الذي اتى الى المنطقه
العربيه لاجراء دراسه هو الاهداف الاختلاف
في الاهداف فالباحث العربي يتناول
دراسه هذه المجتمعات للوصول الى حقائق
تاريخيه تفيد في توثيق تاريخه بينما
المستشرق كان هد هدف سياسي لوجستي بامتياز
واحيانا استخبارات واحيانا استخبارات عرفت
كيف هذا صحيح طيب ما هو رايك اليوم تعرف
علم الاجتماع المهم جدا يعني وهو مدخل من
مداخل فهم الذي يجري ومن ثم اتخاذ القرار
الصحيح بناء على هذا الفهم المواسع حضرتك
واستاذ فيه وتعرف تشعباته وتعرف لدرجه انك
تخصصت في مجال محدد المجتمع البداوه ما
واقع الدراسات الاجتماعيه اليوم في
الاكاديميه وخليني اقول بشكل محدد عشان ما
نصير مبعثرين
داخل الجامعات او خارج اروي قتل الجامعات
ايش رايك في منتجات الدراسات الاجتماعيه
تعرف نمر بتحولات اجتماعيه ضخمه من فتره
طويله هل تم الدراسات تحلل وتشرع وتشرح
وترصد هذه التحولات هذه الان المجتمعات
العربيه تمر بحاله نوعيه من التغيرات
والتطورات في بنيتها المجتمعيه والمجتمع
السعودي في اولى او طليعه هذه المجتمعات
الان الدراسات التي تجري لدراسه هذه
التغيرات وهذه التنوعات اما دراسه في علم
الاجتماع او علم التاريخ او علم السياسه
في هذه المرحله وفي وضوء خطط
استراتيجيه التنميه المستدامه لرؤيه عشرين
ثلاثين العلم القادر من وجهه نظري على
دراسه هذه الظواهر في التغير وفي التطور
الحضاري السعودي هو علم الانتروبولوجيا
السعوديه
كونه يمتاز بسمتين السمه الاولى هو يستطيع
ان يدرس المجتمع السعودي مراحله الاولى
ومرحلته الان او المراحل الراهنه ويجري
دراسه مقارنه ما بين الماضي والحاضر اضافه
الى ان يستعين بمنهج الانتروبولوجيا
التطبيقيه لتطبيق النتائج العلميه التي
توصلت اليها الانتروبولوجيا السعوديه في
دراسه المجتمع السعودي خلال فترات زمنيه
محدده واماكن جغرافيه محدده مع مقارنتها
بمنجزات الحاضر
بهدف بناء نظريه علميه لبناء مستقبل زاهر
فيما يتعلق بالتطور التنموي السعودي وهذا
تعتقد غير لم نتواصل لم نتواصل حتى على
مثل ما يقول اخواننا المصريين بعافيه
حبتين حتى يعني علم الانتروبولوجيا الى
الان لا يدرس في الجامعه السعوديه في
معرفتي يعني لا يدرس مع العلم انك تدعو
الى انشاء انتربولوجيا السعوديه
بحد ذاتها لا تدرس حتى الان بالضبط
صراحه كلام يعني يعني يدعو الى التامل
وربما التغيير وعلى ذكر الانتربولوجيا
السعوديه او السعوديه حضرتك اصدرت مجموعه
من الكتب والابحاث حول التاريخ السعودي
حاولت ان تركز فيها على مثل ما قراتنا في
كتابك هذا الدوله السعوديه
وقيمها المجتمعيه
درست فيها القيامه الاجتماعيه للسعوديه في
عهدها الاول في الدوله الاولى محركات
الاخلاقيه والقيميه حتى في مجال الاقتصاد
والسياسه ولك ايضا كتب اخرى
تحاولت فيها ان تتناول زوايا اخرى ما هي
مصادرك حينما درست التاريخ السعودي
بالنسبه للمجتمع السعودي او الدوله
السعوديه الاولى مصاديرها محدوده هي اشخاص
عاصروا احداثها
والوثائق العثمانيه التي كانت
عباره عن مراسلات ما بين الولاه
العثمانيين والسلطنه العثمانيه تصف واقع
هذه الدوله واحداثها ومجرياتها وما يحدث
فيها اسمحلي دكتور الارشيف العثماني دائما
اشوف الاشاره الي كثير تتردد بين الباحثين
يعني سعوديين وغير سعوديين عرب وغير عرب
هل هو على هذه الدرجه من الاهميه فيما يخص
تاريخ الجزيره العربيه الان اي دراسه تريد
ان تتناول تاريخ الجزيره العربيه في
الاربع عقود او الخمس عقود في القمس قرون
الماضيه لا بد لك من اللجوء او الذهاب الى
الارشيف العثماني كون هذه المنطقه كانت
تحت الحكم الدوله العثمانيه مباشره او
بشكل هذه المنطقه مسجل تسجيل دقيق من خلال
وثائق ومراسلات ومحفوظه في الارشيف
العثماني نعم انا من رواد الارشيف
العثماني وقد اطلعت على وثائق الدوله
السعوديه الاولى كامله في قلب الارشيف
العثماني وما وخاصه ما يتعلق بالحملات
العثمانيه حمل الطوسون احمد باشا وحمله
ابراهيم باشا على الدرعيه هذا الملف عدده
انا حصلت على 118 وثيقه تم دراستها
وترجمتها وتحليلها وتفريغها واستنباط
الهدف الاساسي من دراسات الثلاث وهو
النضال الوطني السعودي المشرف في مقاومه
الغزاه
كل الدراسات او مجمل الدراسات التي تحدثت
عن تاريخ الدوله السعوديه الاولى يعني
اغفلت ثلاث نقاط النقطه الاولى التاريخ
الحقيقي لنشوء الدوله السعوديه الاولى وهو
1139 لحظه تولي محمد بن سعود لعماره
الدرعيه وهو مرحله مبايعه الامام محمد بن
سعود بعد ان وحد شطري الدرعيه المليبي
واخصيبه وبدا ببناء الدرعيه وتحقيق
الاستقرار المجتمعي والامن الاجتماعي
والعدل والمساواه واسس واتخذ من الدرعيه
عاصمة لدوله
الامر الامر الثاني هي القيم المجتمعيه
الحقيقيه التي نشات عليها الدوله السعوديه
الاولى اذا كانت دوله تتحرك وفق مسطره من
القيم نعم ومحددات من هذه القيم استكرت
قبل قليل دكتور عن الارشيف العثماني كاني
فهمت من حديث سابق لك انه الموت المتاح
للباحثين منه الان رغم ضخامته لكن لا
يتجاوز 10% يعني عند الحوالي 90% لم تتح
للباحثين اصلا لما بسبب انه ما زالت موجود
في الاظابير والخزائن او لاسباب اخرى يعني
استاذي الارشيف العثماني في كم كبير من
الوثائق وخاصه وثائق المنطقه العربيه
الارشيف العثماني لم يصنف منه الان الا
سوى 35% وياخذون عينات
في حين نسبه 65% من الوثائق ومحتويات
الارشيف العثماني ما زالت مجهوله بالنسبه
حتى للاطراك وباء الباحث غير
وهذه الوثائق تحتوي كنوز من المعلومات
وخاصه في تاريخ الجزيره العربيه
خريطه عثمانيه
رسمت او وضعت سنه 1211 للهجره وهي الخريطه
العسكريه التي هاجم بها ابراهيم باشا
الدرعيه عن ابراهيم باشا قبل يحاصر
الدرعيه اعتمد او هذه الخريطه هذه الخريطه
هذه اللغه هذه الخريطه وضعت على زمن حمل
الطوسون باشا
التي فشلت
وانهزمت في
الخريطه هذه الخريطه تبين خريطه عسكريه
خريطه عسكريه اهميتها تبين ان قوات
ابراهيم باشا كانت تتمركز في هذه المنطقه
واول حي هاجمه حي الطريف وهو الان الموجود
في قصور سلوى ثم حي البجيري والان في
ساريه علم المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وهذا على ما يبدو انه الطريق الان الذي
يمثل طريق الملك خالد طريق الملك خالد
وهذا تقريبا
بالمكان هذا تقريبا عسكري ابراهيم عسكر
بها قوات ابراهيم باشا كانت عسكر بهذه
المنطقه وهذا تصنيف الوثيقه وهي رقمها في
رقمها في الارشيف العثماني وفي صوره
محفوظه في منها في مكتبه الباحث سعودي
يعقوب برشيد دغيثر نعم نعم وهذه خريطه
عسكريه وجدت في الارشيف وجدت في الارشيف
حتى شوف مكتوب فيها هنا هي ما زالت في
العثمانيه
قبل الطويق
عرفت كيف وجبل زهره وهذه هي وثيقه عثمانيه
عرفت
العثماني انه ممكن الدكتور مثلها الوثيقه
ذي حتى الوانها جميله يعني الارشيف
العثماني هل حافل بمفاجات قد تغير راينا
الايذاء بعض الاحداث والشخصيات التاريخيه
نعم على سبيل المثال الحقائق التي اظهرتها
دراسات الثلاث التي
نشرت في يوم التاسيس السعودي 1444
اثبتت التاريخ الحقيقي للدوله السعوديه
1139 اثبتت ان الدوله السعوديه الاولى
نشات على مجموعه من القيم المجتمعيه ذات
الطابع الامني الامني الامني حيث ان
المجتمع في نجد والجزيره العربيه انذاك
كان يعاني من حاله من التفكك الاجتماعي
والاقتصادي والسياسي بسبب غياب او غياب
وجود حكم مركزي قوي يكون قادر على فرض
الامن والاستقرار الاجتماعي وحفظ امن طرق
قوافل الحج والتجاره والسابله فهذا الامر
الامام محمد بن سعود رحمه الله من خلال
موروثه السياسي العريق والذي يمتد الى سنه
850 للهجره على زمن جده من على مريضه الذي
اسس حكمه السياسي في الدرعيه ادرك هذه
الحقيقه التاريخيه بانه يتوجب عليه بناء
حكم سياسي قوي يقوم على فرض الامن على فرض
الامن بس عند نقطه الامل دكتور تسمح له
تفضل لانه داهمنا البوليس الوقت الامن
فسناخذ فاصل وجيزه تهمني حكايه الامن
وكانه هو الباعث او الاساس في انبعاث
الكيان السياسي للدوله ففاصل وجيز لا تذهب
بعيدا الحديث سيحلو لكم
[موسيقى]
اهلا وسهلا بكم من جديد حديثنا كان وما
يزال عن تاريخ السعوديه وتاريخ الجزيره
العربيه من خلال استعراض او قيمه الارشيف
العثماني كما من خلال استعراض علم اجتماع
البداوه وشريكنا في الندوه الدكتور
اسماعيل سلامات الباحث في مجال علم
الاجتماع بشكل خاص علم الاجتماع البداوه
له مجموعه من الدراسات عن التاريخ السعودي
الحديث من اهمها او من الطفها هذه الدراسه
الدوله السعوديه الاولى وقيمها المجتمعيه
قلت في هذه الدراسه الدكتور اسماعيل وكنت
تتحدث قبل الفاصل ان ثمه امر يقفل عنه
كثيرا وهو ان الامن وتحقيق الامن والوحده
السياسيه هو المحرك الاول لنشاه الدوله
السعوديه الاولى وهذا يتعارض مع نظريات
البعض ممن يقول ان الباعث لقيام الدوله
السعوديه هو مجرد الدعوه الدينيه
والاصلاحيه في حين ان اللي فهمت من دراستك
وكلامك انه الدعوه الدينيه هي هي جزء من
مكونات هذه الدوله لكن سكان نجد كيف كان
حسب دراساته سكان نجد كيف كان وضعهم
الديني قبل الدوله السعوديه الحياه
الاجتماعيه والدينيه قبل تاسيس الدوله
السعوديه الاولى يمكن ان ننجزها لك بما
يلي
الدين الاسلامي موجود وهناك من يلتزم
بتطبيق الشرائع وهناك من لا يلتزم والصوره
التي ضخمها الباحث العربي ابن بشر بان
الحياه الاجتماعيه يسودها
حاله من الكفر والفقر والجهل والبدع
عباده بذلك المستوى
الاساس في نشوء الدوله السعوديه الاولى هو
حاجه المجتمع في نجد
والجزيره العربيه الى تحقيق حكم سياسي
مركزي يقوم على فرض الامن وخاصه امن قوافل
الحج والتجاره والسائله والسابله الماره
في خاصه قوافل قوافل الاحساء الماره
بالعارض والمتجه الى مكه والمدينه وهذه
المهمه التي
ركز عليها الامام محمد بن سعود ليست وليده
اللحظه انذاك بل اجداده من قبله كانوا
يقومون بهذه المهمه
[موسيقى]
الدوله السعوديه قيمها انه السبب الرئيسي
وهذا التلخيص لكلامك اللي تفضلت فيه قبل
قليل في ظهور الدوله السعوديه هو انتشار
الفوضى
وغياب الامن والامان والعدل والمساواه
وقطع طرق الحج والعمر والعمره والتجاره
فهذا اللي توصلت لحضرتك وهو تلخيص مثل هذه
الاوضاع تصحيح هذه الاوضاع بخلق الاستقرار
والامن ونشر العدل والمساواه هذه عوامل
ساهمت في نشوء وتطور الدرعيه واصبحت
تميز المشروع السعودي يعني في امارات كانت
موجوده في موجوده في العيينه في غيرها في
حتى في المناطق شمال نجد وكذا ولكن لم
تتسم بهذه السمه الرؤيه الوحدويه هذه او
الرؤيه الشامله الامام محمد بن سعود
استخدم سياسه المسامحه وحسن الجوار وبدا
بمساعده حكام الاقاليم او المناطق
المجاوره لتحقيق الاستقرار في بلادهم
معناته عنده مشروع الرجل وعندما ادرك
هؤلاء الامراء جدوى سياسه الايمان بن سعود
انضموا الى دولته طواعيه نعم
انت هذه المرحله الاولى محمد بن سعود
لمرحله التاسيس بالمناسبه هي يوم التاسيس
نسبه اليه قلت ايضا في موضع اخر من هذا
الكتاب
واعجبتني هذه اللقطه تقول بعدما استعرضت
جهود محمد بن سعود الاولى كثيرا ما تظلم
من الامانه ثم قلت فنشات وحده في العارض
ثم وحده في نجد يعني العارضه احد اقاليم
نجد كان الاساس توحيد العارض ثم من خلفه
استكمال مشروع التوحيد في نجمه في الجزيره
العربيه حتى حتى وصلت حدود الدوله
السعوديه الاولى من التوسع والانتشار الى
نواحي السيناء والى حلب في سيناء والى حلب
في بلاد الشام في سوريا الان والى كربلاء
في العراق الدوله السعوديه الاولى من
الرغم من حيث المساحه الجغرافيه هي اكبر
كيان سياسي سعودي عبر التاريخ هل هذا الذي
اخاف العثمانيين وربما غير العثمانيه عيسى
العثمانيين حتى يمكن الاوروبيين او اللي
فهمت منك
السبب الرئيسي
بالحكم على وائد الدوله السعوديه الاولى
هو انتشارها وتوسعها واخذ مكانتها
الطبيعيه بحيث ان الدول الكبرى مثل
بريطانيا روسيا
الدوله العثمانيه اصبحت تخاف على مصالحها
في هذه المنطقه فهذا الهدف
وحد بينهم
وزودوا الدوله العثمانيه والجيش المصري
باعتى واحدث الاسلحه الحربيه التي
استخدموها في اي لحظه هذا عكس ما يشيعه
بعض
نسميهم مثقفين وما ادري ايش يعني من
تيارات قوميه وهي سريع عربيه انه دوله
السعوديه الاولى هي صنيعه انجليزيه
بالتالي انت انت من واقع دراساتك تقول
يعني كيف موضوع الاسلحه وش تقصد بالاسلحه
فرنسا زودت جيش ابراهيم محمد علي باشا
بمدافع باحدث المدافع التي يمتلكها الجيش
الفرنسي وباحدث بنادق القنص
وزودتهم ايضا برومات فرنسيين فرنسيين
منهم في سينار مهند هو المهندس شاركوا في
الحمله وهم المخططون للهجوم على الدرعيه
اعرف كيف وكانوا ركن اساسي في جيش ابراهيم
باشا من حيث الاستشارات وتنفيذ
الدوله لماذا لان الحكومه الفرنسيه خشيت
من التوسع الحاصل للدوله السعوديه الاولى
واخذ دورها كدوله اصبحت لها مكانه عالميه
مستقله
وشريكه اساسيه في صنع القرار الدولي انذاك
وليس صنع تابع مستقل مستقل
اصبحت الدوله السعوديه الاولى بقوتها قوه
مكافئه لفرنسا وروسيا والدوله العثمانيه
نفسها فلذلك تامرت عليها هذه الدول
للتقليل من اول القضاء على ثقلها السياسي
والاجتماعي والعسكري وديني بالاضافه ان
الدوله السعوديه الاولى اصبح لها انصار
حتى في الهند حتى في بلاد الشام حتى في
مصر نفسه حتى في فرنسا اصبح لها انصار
وموالين لماذا بسبب الاثر الايجابي الذي
انعكس على حياه الناس من العدل المساواه
الرخاء الاستقرار والامن واصبحت الدرعيه
انذاك
قبله للناس اصبحوا الناس يهاجرون الى
الدرعيه للعيش بامن وامان
وبكرامه وبرفاه وايضا اشاره الانجليز
دكتور
مشهوره رحله الكابتن سادلير وهو كابتن
مبعوث من الطرف البريطاني لتهنئه ابراهيم
باشا بعد ان احرق الدرعيه
وارتكب ما ارتكب هناك فذهب اليه وحاول ان
يقابله في الدرعيه هذا الكتاب منشور ثم لم
تسعف الحظ قابله في الحناكيه قرب المدينه
هذا الخبر ذكرته في كتابي بطولات حصار
الدرعيه وبطولات السعوديه عندما تمكن
ابراهيم باشا بسبب عوامل عديده من دخول
الدرعيه واحتلالها انا لا اعتبر انه ان
دخول الدرعيه سقوط هو احتلال من احتلال
الدرعيه بدات بدا ملوك
كبريات الدول العالميه بتهنئه محمد علي
باشا بهذا الانجاز الذي
كانوا يخافون من توسع ونفوذ الدوله
السعوديه الامام محمد بن سعود اصبح صاحب
قرار محلي واقليمي ودولي ثم الامام عبد
العزيز ثم الامام عبد العزيز حضرتك ذكرت
نص جميل الصراحه نص شاعري بس هو شاعري بس
حقيقي مش مجازي نقلا عن المستشرق الشهير
والمؤرخ نعتبر المؤرخ سعودي رغم انه
بريطاني اللي هو الحاج عبد الله فلبي
النص يقول
وهو يستعرض بدايات الدوله بدايات تاسيس
الدرعيه مانع المريدي يقول لم يكن هذا
النص فيلبي لم يكن قد مضى على وفاه
تيمورلانك الا اقل من نصف قرن
وكان لا يزال مقدرا للعرب ان يبقوا في
اسبانيا يعني الاندلس نصف قرن اخر وقبل ان
يكتشف هذه الفتاه انتباهيه وقبل ان يكتشف
كولومبوس امريكا بنصف في قرن ايضا في تلك
في ذلك الوقت توجه سنه 1446 ميلادي تكلمت
850 هجري مواطن هو يقوم من اهل القطيف ومن
ضاحيه هناك تسمى الدرعيه ليزور ابن عمه
ابن درع بن درع الحنفي طبعا هنا في الرياض
الذي كان قد استقر منذ زمن بعيد الى اخره
نشاه الدرعيه كعماره حديثه سابق لقيام
امريكا او لاكتشاف كولومبوس لامريكا حسب
كلام فلبي صحيح فاذا يعني تاريخ عريق
تتكلم يعني الحكم السعودي او العمق
التاريخي انتروبولوجيا للحكم السعودي عمق
تاريخي قديم يمتد من سنه 850 للهجره اي
ليس حتى ليس ولاده سنه 1139
قلنا الامتداد الامتداد
التاريخيولوجيا في الجانب السياسي
حسب المصادر العلميه ذكرته سنه 850 للهجره
طيب اخر شيء دكتور داهمنا
جمله وجيزه هل تعتقد انه تم الافاده من
الارشيف العثماني بشكل الكافي والى ماذا
تدعو يعني ما هي المبادرات التي يمكن
الافاده منها بالنسبه الى ما هو معروض
الان من الارشيف العثماني بنو الباحثين
حقائقهم واستنتاجاتهم
ونتائج دراساتهم ولكن انا اتوقع في ظهور
المزيد من الوثائق العثمانيه والسجلات سوف
تظهر حقائق جديده وسوف تندثر حقائق الان
نعتبرها مسلمات وخاصه في تاريخ الجزيره
العربيه مثل ما ظهرت وثيقه ابراهيم بن
موسى نعم مثل ما بينتنا قدم وعراقه الحكم
هذه الاسره في الدرعيه في الدرعيه يعني
وحتى في صور اعتقد قلتوغرافيه كمان
السلطان عبد الحميد لم يكشف النقاب على
النقابه انا في الختام اشكرك غايه الشكر
دكتور اسماعيل السلامات على هذا التطواف
الجميل وهو مجرد كما يقال تشويقه
ولكن
المامول اكثر وربما تغري هذه الدقائق
البعض بمتابعه ما تفضلتم بكتابته وبحثه
كما اشكركم
مشاهدينا الكرام ومستمعينا الكرام ولنا
عودات وعودات الى الجزيره العربيه تاريخا
وجغرافيا وثقافه وادبا وقيما ماضيا وحاضرا
ومستقبلا الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]